hey guys welcome to a vlog on the brand
new sony zve10 i'm gonna be talking a
little bit more about this right now we
are in the desert
and we are filming a video with the new
2021 ford bronco
this thing is so awesome
this camera is really great for people
who are looking for a vlogging camera
but not quite just a simple point and
shoot you want to have something that
you can have interchangeable lenses you
want 4k you want that beautiful bokeh
and you want a camera that is not super
crazy expensive this could potentially
be the one for you let's check it out
you could because the body starts at
699.99
and 799.99 with the kit lens 16 to 50
millimeter so here's full zoom
here is all the way out 16 mil you might
notice that this has this
lovely rainbow windscreen here this
actually does come with the white one
but me and my sister have been using
this camera and flying across the united
states
and we have sort of misplaced it i love
the flip up screen and this is very
similar to the a7s
iii and it has this big red record
button on some of the
larger mirrorless cameras they're really
small and they're in like weird
locations so it's really hard to hit and
it also has this cool feature when you
are recording
the screen right here actually has a red
ring around it so you'll
always know if you're recording if
that's not enough there's a red light
directly on the front of this
just to make sure that you know if
you're recording or when you're not it
does have a dedicated
button to switch between the modes you
can switch between photo video and snq
and with snq
you can quickly change those settings to
be either slow-mo
or do like one frame a second which i
usually use to do time lapses this does
have an audio in which is incredible
but it also has a hot shoe here which
will allow you to connect
a few different microphones and you
won't have to have a cable so there's a
bunch of sony ones that are my favorite
that will work with this
audio in so key so it does have usbc
hdmi outs and you can also monitor
audio with headphones right there me and
jenna were joking with this
little windscreen on it looks like a
little clown camera
but so far this camera is great i've
been really enjoying it it's definitely
not as high quality as the a7 s3 but for
the price
you're getting a pretty solid vlog
camera that you can do everything that
you would need to do
so now i'm gonna fly my drone i'm having
a snack so that
while i'm filming i don't get hungry
jenna's gonna be driving
and i'm gonna chase her with a fpv drum
these are really good by the way i also
love this has product showcase
watch how fast this focus is are you
proud of showcasing your snacks
yeah product showcase these are so good
me
the snack okay i'm flying remember when
i came out to the desert to do cool fpv
drone shots of the bronco
and forgot the cable
and the controller yeah i remember
i'm still living it
[Music]
one of the things that i wanted to test
out with this is putting on the xlr hot
shoe now the one that i'm using right
now is what we use for all of our shoots
it's great because not only can we
attach a little wireless receiver here
so i can be wirelessly transmitting
to the microphone but i can also just
throw on a shotgun mic as well
which we don't have attached here but
you can now i want to do some lens tests
this is the zv ones this is kind of sort
of a comparison but the thing with this
is it is
basically just a point and shoot camera
and you don't have the ability to change
these lenses
but with this you can change it make it
look more cinematic or basically just
get any shot you want
lenses it's all about the lenses
i have got a bag full of aps-c lenses
and i'm really excited about this
because
the fact that you can change up these
lenses will give you an entirely new
look depending upon what you're looking
for
this lens right here is the lens that i
used to vlog with for years
this lens has been around the world and
back again
this is the 10 to 18 and why i love this
so much is because it had such a wide
angle that no matter where i was
i was always in frame my subjects were
in frame and it was really great for
landscape and travel
this is an 18 to 200. i actually haven't
tried this lens yet so i'm definitely
excited to try this one out they've got
a 24 millimeter
we have a 18 to 135 and last but not
least we have a 50 mil
one eight yeah this is it this is the 10
to 18 like look at this like this is so
wide
angle like look at this look at this
look at this i'm zooming in i'm zooming
out i'm zooming in i'm zooming out
it's so good so this is like kind of
like the vlogging length
see that's nice it's nice
zoom in zoom out
so this is the 18 to 200. the best part
about this is
we can zoom in all the way to 200
millimeters
okay so so this one is an 18 to 135
which is very similar to the 18 to 200
but look at this zoom look at that zoom
look at that zoom
nice nice nice nice nice yeah i like
this little lens this is cool
this is the 24 millimeter 1 8 and we
actually don't have any nd filters for
these lenses
but we're going to hold one over top of
it so we can actually get this to the 1
8 setting so right now it's at f8 so
this is f18 without an nd filter
and tyler is bringing in our filter
here we go how's it look
oh that does look really good check that
out look at that
oh wow oh i'm
shook
okay now take off the nd filter let's
see
yeah that's real bright guys nd filters
are freaking magic
wow so we're gonna do the same thing
with this 50 millimeter 1
8 holding up that nd filter makes such a
huge difference i don't really have many
of the aps-c
lenses because we do mostly shoot with
full-frame so most of the filters that i
have
are for full-frame lenses so that's why
we're having to do this little make
shift operation here
but it's working so this is the 50
millimeter one eight we're doing the
same kind of method here holding up the
nd filter
and let's see what it looks like without
it yeah no
it's just there you go there you go
look at that bokeh this lens is
incredible actually and i love that this
is one of the silver ones too so it kind
of matches the white body way better
wow this looks good i'm impressed i'm
impressed so we have both the zv1
right here and the zve 10 right here now
one of the things that is really cool is
that they do
have on-board audio and the audio is
actually really good but right now we're
recording with a third camera using that
audio so that it is all the same
but i do want to do a little test where
you can see what it sounds like with
each camera
so first i'm testing out the zv1 audio
you can hear some car noise in the
background
but that's kind of you know it is what
it is when you're vlogging you're going
to have these things
but each one of these do have the little
wind sock on top of them to protect it
from the wind
it is a little windy so you can see look
look at this the hair is moving
we have now switched the audio over to
the zved10
and it's gonna be cool to kind of see
what these both sound like
i'm just gonna keep talking and saying
some things about all of the things
i'm actually using lenses right now to
uh
to prop both of these cameras up because
why not so there we go
that's our test with both cameras side
by side so far my first impressions of
this camera is it's actually really nice
now the thing is i'm so used to shooting
with full-frame cameras
that are so super high-end so doing
comparisons between those types of
cameras is really difficult but so far
i'm very impressed with this and i think
this is really a great camera if you're
looking to save money
but also still have that interchangeable
lens feature and with that you're going
to be able to upgrade your lenses and be
able to get some really great shots
i also love that this does have hdmi out
so if you want to use this as
a webcam for streaming or doing things
like that i love everything that sony
has been doing they've been actually
listening to creators and giving us the
things that we actually need so sony
thank you so much
and i hope you guys enjoy this video and
i hope that you uh
have a good day i didn't really know how
to end
the video so wishing you a good day
this is the best that i could come up
with all right i'll see you later bye
[Music]